Welcome to this AI Coffee Break!
Today we will follow the development of Transformers
for image recognition even further, by discussing
the Transformer in Transformer paper!
It's fresh out on ArXiv!
This paper comes to alleviate the issue that
Transformers on images have so far handled
the image as a sequence of patches
without modelling the structure inside the
patch.
So this paper puts a Transformer into the
Transformer to do this job!? Yeah, and it
beats the DeiT Transformer model on ImageNet
with similar computational cost.
In this video, we will show you how.
If you want Ms. Coffee Bean to give you a
quick reminder about Transformer models for
image recognition so far, check out the ViT
video that shows how transformers can beat
ImageNet state of the art with a lot of data,
and the DeiT video showing how transformers
can be made more data-efficient so that they
do not need such huge amounts of data.
Find the links in the description below.
So today’s story begins with the DeiT Transformer
from Facebook achieving impressive results
on ImageNet with 86,4M parameters and 17,6B
FLOPs improving the data-efficiency of ViT
from Google.
Is there anything more to be to be done than
that?
Well, Vision Transformers so far have been
splitting the image into a sequence of patches.
But Transformers need vectors, not 2d patches,
therefore the patches are transformed into
an image vector by a linear projection for
example.
But here, in the transformation from a 2d
patch to a vector, the internal pixel structure
of the patch is lost.
So it is time for the Transformer in Transformer,
or short TNT, to come in and model both local
and global information.
The authors of TNT also split the image into
a sequence of patches. These patches are p
by p pixels,
where p is set to 16, for example. So until
here everything is like we are used to from
ViT or DeiT.
But now is where the crazy part happens:
For TNT the authors reshape each patch to
a super-pixel sequence!!!
A what? Let’s take it slow.
So the idea of TNT is to model patches better
than just cramping them into a single vector.
For this, each patch that is actually of stack
of 3 matrices for red, green and blue, is
transformed to something else,
which is a tensor of p’ times p’ and c
channels. P prime is chosen to be four and
even though Ms. Coffee Bean could not find
this explicitly written in the paper, she
guesses that this c under the assumption of
no information loss has to be something like
p x p x 3 initial channels divided by p' times
p'.
Just a hunch.
Then, if p’ equals 2 this new tensor can
be regarded as a set of 4 pixels which are
now superpixels, because they already contain
information about their neighboring pixels.
Remember, we reduced from p to p' and p is
bigger than p'.
In reality, these superpixels visualized for
the whole image look like this: So now you
see where this is going.
We have a sequence of superpixels
that represent a patch and
they themselves are actually vectors,
see?
So we have here two sequences at different
levels of granularity.
We have the pixel sequence representing a
patch
and the patch sequence representing the whole
image.
So we have an inner Transformer block that,
you know, does self-attention transformer
magic on the pixel level.
Then we have an outer Transformer block on
image patch level, where the image patches
are represented by a vector in the same way
previous work did. And now the inner and outer
transformer are combined: What comes out of
the inner transformer
is concatenated
and then linearly projected to fit the dimension
of the outer Transformer representation, which
is then added to the patch embedding before
it is processed by the outer transformer.
So the outer transformer now works on patch
level and on the representations that
were computed by the inner transformer on
the pixel level.
And of course, what we have visualized here
for one patch, is done for all. And we have
also not shown the positional embeddings,
which are present at both patch level and
pixel level for the Transformer to have an
idea about the location of things in the image,
which is not clear from the set of vectors
alone.
And this was it for the Transformer in Transformer!
We strongly recommend you to check out the
paper for really cool stuff.
You can see not only that the TNT features
are richer and meaningful for human judgement,
but you also see DeiT features. I always wondered
how they look like!
You can read in the paper see how the learnt
features by TNT transfer to other benchmark
datasets.
It's a crazy time for the Transformers!
They do this, they do that, they are everywhere.
Hey, do not forget to like and subscribe
and to share out the content.
Ok, bye!